- welcome h3r me we go to war today
against I don't why do I always have to
go to war we're making love today today
we are having a lovemaking fest because
with us is the illustrious
multi-talented scooter riding mega
vaping bull cutted madman mega talent
musician sweetheart
fashion icon whoo what's poppin baby oh
thank you for having me
also Oliver is on tour starting and odd
guests get your tickets right now at
Oliver tree music calm twelve cities are
already sold out so get on that website
pronto am i right woo because you are
not gonna be able to be getting tickets
if you wait too dang long oh this [ __ ]
is selling out it's about 80% sold out
so if you want to get a ticket now is
the [ __ ] time and I also do want to
say thank you to our sponsors honey and
hymns with that being said
congratulations to you on and let me
start with congratulating you guys on a
baby a beautiful baby boy thank you soon
I wanted to present you guys with a
little something I have a little
something for ya oh man you know how to
make a boy a becoming heir with gifts
so yeah so we're actually doing a fall
line of baby clothes we're partnering
with Gerber I was thinking maybe this
would be a good chance to let young
fyodor try these out and you know try
the prototype out so a little
something-something we have a couple
different designs here oh that's another
quality print thank you so much guys
yeah check out this is my favorite
design notice here a Gerber ok kidding
Gerber does make clothing yes this is my
favorite design he's gonna wear it
that's the same thing but with 6 that's
what I'm talking about we did a wash
these are they ready to go these are
cleaned up dude I had my guy wash them
your guy huh yeah I've got a buddy guy
yeah and then um oh it's on both sides
[ __ ] that's trippy yeah don't think I
forgot about you guys I know I missed
the baby shower but uh I have a little
something for you guys as well it's not
much but you know I wanted to get you
something as a token of gratitude and
and as good faith to being you know
incredible new parents so so much can I
get a drumroll
yes we do have a drumroll hang tight do
we have a drumroll
we got a drumroll standby okay well it's
kind of it kind of defeats the purpose
really what's the drumroll oh yeah okay
there we go
you got it okay we've got a black satin
yeah there's something underneath it
what do we have under the sheet David
Blaine oh he dropped it so this is a
portrait my super made free me do though
my sister is a huge fan of you guys know
introduced me to you a couple years ago
oh this is a portrait what we have here
behind us is the redwood forest it takes
place in Santa Cruz
we're both we both I mean you're from
Santa there's a Santa Cruz connection
there is we'll talk about that we'll get
there yeah what we have here though we
got a little UCSC banana slug slug ya
got shredder up in the tree holy and
just you know a little family portrait
my favorite vape and of course we got
Theodore with the Stax oh yeah my only
question for you guys is have you found
a godfather yet we just found a gun oh
when you give me that photo you could
what does it mean to be a godfather
though here's what I'm thinking does
that I think we can train this kid to be
a protege you didn't give him the best
clothing video so far I mean yes so far
if we're just if we're giving Godfather
title out based on gifts alone I think
you would win that means the world I'm
not sure that's gonna be partners not
sure so yes your Godfather what does it
mean well hold on I can't tell you I am
serious but before I give you the title
I need to know what it means to you but
it doesn't mean you can just pop in I'm
gonna be all it doesn't mean you can
just pop in anything bro I'm gonna be
coming over all that we need to talk we
need allies control know like I'm just
thinking like we'll just be hanging on
weekends and you guys need some help and
I'll be like bro I'll teach him piano
like
I started piano lessons very young at
age two so like it's never too early to
start this guy I think we could get him
to write his first song by age three if
we move down bring kids with you on tour
do you know definitely not he'll stay at
home but I think you know when I'm mad I
know about the whole my depression
documenting this isn't a way to be able
to I didn't want it to go there guys we
could switch real fast
but we know why us I'll just change the
subject by just saying I have another
gift and oh yeah well the first of all
also what's the name of your sister tell
me your sister honestly I don't really
want to get into okay but I do want to
tell her um she made me with my favorite
shirt that I own like how did you know
well obviously fan she's a huge fan well
thank you to her who shall remain
nameless for now but god bless her this
is her name if you really want to know
itzchak Weesa it's up its up Teresa
Olivia no I'm serious
Jack huesca jacquees aside I want to say
I need mess up the name Jack Weesa Jack
we said tree no it's not my last name
but I'm not gonna say my last name
because I don't really want to get into
that right now trying to keep it like a
little bit smoother starts let's start
with some lighter so Jay Jay yeah JT
okay so I'm just trying to see you see
if you have more gifts I have one more
okay well let's get it away and the
intern in today yeah of course Ian's
always here right he can we get him out
here is Ian here today he's sleeping you
can try you think that way you know we
always have to ask a lot of those time
for him I love that painting by the way
thank you I really I'm trying not to be
wrong holy [ __ ] you look amazing dude
yeah are you doing something different
with your hair oh is this new shampoo
woke up like this I don't know what
happened we look like oh hey sis or some
[ __ ]
I know Rader started I got a little
something for you it's not much but I
have a custom Oliver tree fidget spinner
I don't know if we can get that kazoom
din enough this thing is one of a kind
they literally only made one so you're
the only one who has when it whoa get it
yeah what the [ __ ] he's doesn't do [ __ ]
he's answer bro I'm a huge fan of his
research thank you
you did on Bella Duveen really
impressive stuff someone in here
appreciates his powerpoints are some of
the most powerful powerpoints I've ever
seen thank you they have a lot of points
blessings blessing but Ian rachet though
Ian's been kind of revolting against me
later he doesn't like being on the show
anymore what's the deal dude
I say NC you came in here this is your
fault I didn't come on
you got your food spinner now you got it
I got it thank you all thank you we love
him he's the best the problem with Ian
is that no he's so funny and he's so
likable and everyone likes him but he
doesn't like being on camera right so I
on one hand want to respect his Irish I
do respect also he's true he's a true
artist where he will not make a
PowerPoint unless he thinks it's worth
it and we keep telling him we want more
right
I was completely [ __ ] with him
there's my guys can share that I was
thinking we could give that over to
Theodore but if you guys want more you
know bro that's a really smooth glide I
know that's what I'm saying like this is
really high we literally got to come to
the creme yeah I don't know if anything
else that's it
all right well thank you for being here
thank you for the gifts thanks for
having me oh yeah you know I think you
know that's really enough fun and games
I think we should really get down to it
I mean you're let's get down you're a
babe guy I'm a babe God uh let's just do
what the people want to see here I we do
a little good old-fashioned vape off
okay well I'm glad you brought that up
yes we should and first of all let me
just say you come you say you're the
vape God and I think that's an issue we
have some computer sounds going on here
dan what was that oliver is distracted
Dan you really messed up oh I first of
all have to make a vape disclaimer
because YouTube's out of control what's
going on there's no weed in our Papes
what
there's no weed and our vapes what's up
with the marijuana logo it's there's not
we put tape over here over well mine is
just pure wheat no I don't say that
because YouTube elects Miley not we yeah
that's better we can recall its pure VG
right there's no there's no nicotine
it's just pure VG there's no anything
it's a harmless fun little gag don't
vape it's gluten for you not very free
we do it
so now wholly free let us do our thing
but I don't like that you're coming off
calling yourself the vape God well dude
it's nothing to disrespect but I didn't
even come up with that name myself
that's just what people started calling
me I just went with it I mean the drill
is pretty epic you're more like a vape
Prince though of like I don't know I
guess how do you see it let's just here
I want to hear you out I mean and let's
bring someone else in who maybe is you
you know competing for this time let's
well let's just compete and let it speak
for itself who's the gun who's the print
that's the way to do this so first of
all do you have your weaponry with you
of course I bring it everywhere so let's
bring it in could you have a guy who can
bring it you're gonna grab it I'm gonna
grab it your jewel reminds me of like
clouds weapon from Final Fantasy you
know like a vape sword
oh yeah he's on standby well okay Dan's
bring it in my weaponry yeah I mean dude
come on I can't even carry this do it
I'm too weak you can you can put it
right here thank you so much appreciate
that so let's just get a look at the
gear here before we babe oh thank you
Dan
thank you kindly appreciate that okay
good thank you everybody so we had so
here we have Oliver let's get a shot so
here is the biggest jewel ever made can
we say that oh you're coming apart there
yeah so tell me about your jewel so this
thing is 6,000 watts I set it up so that
we have the full mod kit on there what
you're seeing here is easily the most
powerful vape that's ever been designed
for human consumption at least let's
hear a little bit about your vape I'm
seeing something it's a lot smaller in
person okay so so that's funny that you
said it's the most powerful vape ever
devised because this thing weighs
it's got 150 batteries you said how much
watts is that one this one's six million
there's nothing [ __ ] this [ __ ] power
really batteries this one side dude you
think I'm dumb
bro this could power a small city okay
this has powered a small city it has
which city I'm not getting in just hit
the damn thing on the count of three
let's just hit this yeah we should wait
at a time that's technology and I want
to measure the cloud size right do you
think goes first is ela impartial judge
I think so yeah of course of course
okay that goes without saying yes she's
she'll take any opportunity to uh here's
what I'm thinking me down a peg no you
go first you want me to go first old
timers go first all time sorry what do
you mean luck you say to me okay do you
want to call me old timer
old man yeah I have a child now so it's
fair enough you're gonna be a grandpa
call me grandpa call me grandpa after
this [ __ ] grandpa
that's literally nothing dude that's a
[ __ ] joke you said that is how many
watts six six million you want to see
one more yes I feel like that was entry
level I'm warming Dara Singh dude there
we go Walmart
okay that was pretty dope little smokey
enough one old man all right let's see
what you got here boy we get a drumroll
hey I didn't get a drumroll no no don't
give him a drumroll that's why I'm the
king
seriously though can you get the
drumroll don't give him a drumroll and
can I get a countdown that's just
disrespectful
all right here we go here I'll give you
this I'll give you the cricket sounds
off-key I'm not hitting it I got
something better you know Philip
DeFranco go ahead get give him a
drumroll yeah dad Zak
this shows not as well as I thought
[Music]
he's hitting it hard he's sucking it in
I'm scared I'm shaking this is a hard
and that was I mean it looked harsh
manic honestly I don't think my manager
charged this thing no that looks usually
his way hard that that looked like a fat
rip for a six thousand jewel though
sixty thousand I thought it was six you
upgraded it to six bro okay so one more
time now that was I mean for a jewel
that was a fat rip that's really what a
vapor hey guys we'll just let the stuff
play I'm gonna take one more hit but you
have to do it to the sub no drumroll
[Laughter]
when you get sucking it in he's hitting
hard he's getting fired's now it came
from the side it was like a t-shape
cloud that looked harsh man we're still
figuring out all the levels you need
like some coils or somehow the judge I
feel like there's no God here on either
side boy are you serious way you saw I
ripped a really fat cloud I mean I'm not
in that Alaba though because I also did
blow nothing right I did take that into
consideration
so what are we might have been the
biggest one yo daddy you can't come in
here on your own evangelist that's yours
he came and broke it and then out vape
me can you get the hell out of here
believe this [ __ ]
well he made us both look like black
poppers all right give me a kickin me a
[ __ ] I'm an out vape that Dan just by
the way Dan just admit on last episode
ia's oral herpes Oh
and now I'm supposed to have a back
that's literally the way my wash is bad
I don't trust his guy to wash Theodore's
laundry anyway whoever that is
do we have an out rubbing alcohol
because I mean Dan goes unless episode
I'm talking about how Bell Delphine has
oral herpes and he goes well 50% of all
people have oral herpes I was like Dan
you have herpes don't you right dude and
he's like yeah I do you're gonna like
that well you said it [ __ ] guy are
you guys like this couple of the other
nothing but I come here and it's like
you start kind of being eggy when I walk
in the shooter cuz I'm late egg and
sorry I'm late and that's not true I'll
let the team speak for himself
what is eggy like egg Shelly yeah man
but he's walking on a sea of eggshells
no no hey let me just say this bro I
have I can only endorse so much
disrespect all right well I'm a very
sensitive guy okay well after this vapor
you're gonna want to leave don't you
dare cuz it's gonna be that fat let's
see I want to see like the real thing
because I keep hearing the drum roll the
drum roll is my thing
okay here we go
[Music]
was that fat that was it thank you I
know I said some stuff I regret saying
but you know what you're a guy that was
a quick turnaround when I see someone
who babe like that doesn't matter how
you talk we love Dan
he just has her fees he admitted in the
last episode he said he has oral herpes
I mean but it's between you know that's
between him and God and me and everyone
listening okay let's go I feel bad I
feel like we let people down we may be
over hyped up this whole vape thing and
I feel like sounds like we let you down
so give us a summary you love your yeah
what would you say how was that I think
that we've had some downs but then there
were some ups and I feel like I didn't
get my full like well that's cuz my
editor just didn't charge the [ __ ] let
me ask you this it's not fully charged
up it's probably out like I would say a
thousand watts right it's not hitting at
full capacity
definitely not hitting it folk about
well let me invite you to hit are her
pee laced vape yeah yeah because this
thing rips fat and I'm gonna give you
some pointers to okay that's not yeah
because if that thing Falls with that
capacity it may explode the building
[Laughter]
fell over and shattered is it okay no
for those reasons I'm out he is leaning
it again yeah it's busted actually is it
really broken no no holy [ __ ] that's not
cool man we got it we got a
who can we blame for that I think in my
van earthquake yeah well those have been
happening I know that's what I'm saying
yeah I think one way we can redeem this
situation you take enough a trip on that
thing I've always wanted to hit this
thing come over here so you should so
first of all you should lift it to get
the full experience
[Music]
if you this thing is powered by a small
nuclear reactor so if you drop it we may
have a miniature Noble so hold it tight
this a baby's what is this this is
literally a baby this is the adorn use
this thing yeah so Oliver is picking up
the master vape right now he's
struggling with the best but he'll get
it on there you go so what I would
recommend to you do to hit this vape
that doesn't have a weed or anything in
it it's just sugar water is it heavy
this is heavier than you thought so hit
the hold the button and let it let it
start to sit a little bit oh there's a
button left hand a red button okay so
let it sizzle a little bit and then suck
in okay there you go
suck baby hit it hard I'll just say it
dude I don't think the technology is
there you the vaping technology has not
caught up to our skill levels not funny
games man enough let's get serious I
think we do have to vapor guards thank
you a lot
let's join hands all of us let's say a
fair dear father and God well let's
honestly give prayer to the one true
vape god I like I weigh Jesus Christ the
one true vape God who blessed us with
the powerful
and the technology that's not quite
there yet but it's getting there amen
amen amen amen amen thank you all right
so let's ask some questions let me I
guess I'll ask you questions is an
interview right right
I guess so man I guess we have to get to
that point of the interview so let me
ask you this [ __ ] I wasn't ready for
this I wasn't prepared for an interview
hey I think we can pass on the interview
I've got a couple more presents I know I
should be saying you're from Santa Cruz
right yeah that's so cool you're Santa
Cruz native SC local so what was your
guy's whole thing about Santa Cruz you
went to UCSC yeah to UCSC I flunked out
I went to kibrit or what was the
Community College oh yeah wait there -
for you maybe we went at the same time
you know I had a better education there
living in a lot straight up do the best
I did because UCSC all the classes I'd
like 500 people and they're clowns oh
your noses oh [ __ ] there's tissue right
there right across from you bro how did
snoc start coming out of your nose bro
that was bad there's a huge Lube popping
out of my boys nose I've been sick for a
while bro just don't hit that babe once
in Santa Cruz I lived there for like
seven or eight years man so I was there
for a while Lila lived there with me for
a year yeah so I was curious what was it
like for you guys as non locals and
Santa Cruz where there's any animosity
towards you is there any kind of vicious
locals coming after you what was that
like well I wanted to ask you something
similar because I know I noticed that
the locals there there is some hostility
straight up I go salt the slugs right so
we always say so did you hate the
students there what was your vibe with
the students in the college basically
you're taught to hate them really no
okay no no it's not like that but there
is a hostility over ownership of the
beach because they're the ones who spend
the most time there and then they
clean it and certain things I treat it
as if it's their main beach the surfers
yeah
the surfers and anyone who just yeah and
so I think it stems with just
frustration of having to share something
that isn't even theirs so I think
they're like confused as far as taking
ownership for something we all own you
know and like we should all have access
to the beach doesn't matter if you live
over the hill but the end of the day you
know there's just I think it comes with
any beach town there's a certain
hostility with over the hill valleys the
slugs and so I'm just here I'm here to
just kind of stop that just let them
know these is for everybody
let them come on down you're gonna jump
in there you can get your ass beat next
is well there's some crazy low I almost
got dude I was at the beach actually it
happened at the beach I was there with
my friends and some drunk local guys
were trying to start some fights with us
we had to bounce nothing we were minding
our own business and they were trying to
Mack on our girls I mean either weren't
together at the time but there was some
girls there I guess I've never
experienced it but I wasn't there enough
and I didn't experience too much of it
on to be honest with you good I'm glad
to hear that I mean I hope it was a good
time I've always wondered what it's like
to grow up there yeah it's it's a trippy
place to grow it is places that can
produce all of our trees got to be a
[ __ ] wild spot we had some wild days
I'll say that but at the end of the day
it's definitely there's a darker side to
it that's pretty plugged-in drug use I
you know me Neela frequently go there
shocked me when I moved there because I
moved there from Israel right well the
first place she moved from Israel yeah
Wow
how was that coming from Israel not I
mean I loved it I still do it's a
virtual place but what you just said
it's so true like it's like everyone
there does drugs and like serious you
know even my a lot of my college friends
ended up like smoking heroin right
getting it some gnarly [ __ ] it's not
just like Oh
it's like serious that's what you do in
the woods like Bonnie Doon these
[ __ ] go and start cooking meth
up there like one it's like something in
the air up in those pine trees or
whatever those redwoods straight up you
know what I'm saying something's off
dude I can't put my finger on it
it's like twin peaks' but meth instead
of like supernatural [ __ ] you got to
stay away from but um I mean either
often go back there yeah and I feel like
I've noticed it more and more like
there's this area or downtown on on a
Pacific like over the bridge what's the
name of that street there the bridge the
connects to Pacific it's like Mission or
some [ __ ] I don't know yeah I'm not good
with names well anyway there's an area
there that's like really just CDs CDs
all hell man it's crazy sure it's a
beautiful place and it yeah it's just
you know I think there's a lot of access
to a lot of drugs there and I think
that's the same everywhere but you know
I think there's something about it's
kind of a bubble people get stuck in
there no like you know it's a good place
to get stuck people are gonna get stuck
somewhere so it's like it's a beautiful
place to get stuck at the end of the day
but um I think there's definitely a
bubble syndrome there yeah absolutely
but it Bette great Mexican food
incredible but in general the food is
incredible other unbelievable you got a
favorite restaurant there
the bagel REE the bagel end of the big
yellow one oh yes where's the big spot
dude there's a couple of them Jack
they're all across the energies but it's
just like the main bagel spot I always
hit him up what's up
shout out have you heard of the bagel
the bagel munchkin all that places Josh
now the bagel munchkins you brought
bagels this cut this little dude who got
in a fight at the bagel store oh I seen
it yeah pretty dull I call him the bagel
muncher I'll [ __ ] that guy that guy's a
legend man we should pull it up now that
we're talking about it I've got it here
no it's a little watch it without audio
yeah you need the audio on that to kind
of get the full experience oh so by the
way a great little what can I find this
is the legend why can I find the video
oh man this shows off the rails
got it before you well anyway it's
commercial time anyway right then yeah
oh that's true we can well let's set up
the bagel boss the bagel boss he's not
really a boss he's more of a munchkin
I'm being Frank that was the name of the
bagel oh that's the name of this store
yeah yeah okay I was like wow that's
really quite generous to him to call my
boss
but regardless won't dig into this when
we come back from the break we've got
all of our tree here I want to watch
some of your music videos I want to dig
into to the music itself because you're
a talented guy you're I think you're a
phenomenal and I would even say and guys
head on over to Culver tree music calm
get some tickets to see this man on
stage with his vape sword yes sir all
right we'll be back
it's coming the biggest shopping day on
the planet yes I'm talking about Amazon
Prime day let's forget for a moment that
their employees have to pee in their
pants and wear diapers to meet quotas
the most insane day of savings across
the air and that's the largest
marketplace marketplace but did you know
there's such a thing as prime day every
day oh that's where honey comes in it's
possible and it's easy because honey is
a free browser extension that searches
the internet for coupon codes and then
like magic automatically applies them to
your cart at checkout now Amazon's
acting like oh is the best deals today
no with honey we always get the best
deals because they scan all the vendors
and make sure you're getting the best
deal because the one that Amazon doesn't
show isn't always the cheapest and the
best deal you can get one cheaper that's
still prime baby and that's what honey
is all about magic when you shop online
honey searches every last one of
Amazon's two million plus sellers to
make sure you're getting the lowest
price possible honey even factors in tax
shipping and prime status what it's
Amazon Prime day every day boy simply
put if there's a better price honey
we'll find it in seconds take for
example this Netgear gaming a router
okay it's usually 78 bucks but when you
see that little honey pop up here take a
look
save eight bucks you click this freaking
button it takes it automatically puts it
in to another vendor that's got the same
gig and it's eight dollars cheaper honey
is a money saving machine it's easy to
install it just takes two freaking
clicks guys prime days coming up but as
prime day every day when you've got
honey it's you got nothing to lose this
the best thing ever add honey for free
at jo-ann honey calm slash age three
that's join honey calm slash age three
for hems calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
thanks to science your dick can be hard
all the freaking time that's Edie baby
it should be optional him connects you
with the real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat your erectile
dysfunction well-known generic
equivalents to name-brand subscriptions
help you combat that empty dick that's
what Edie stands for this prescription
solutions backed by science you answer a
few quick questions you chat with a
doctor for a confidential review
products are shipped directly to your
door
severe Edie isn't just an issue for rich
old guys in fact it affects men in the
30s and 40s as well so guys let's get
that limp sad penis back up to full flak
because there's nothing that gets me
rock hard like a rock that's what's so
gay nothing gives me a rock hard like a
rock-hard penis I mean rock hard in the
that is literally you get is literally
get but like in a metaphorical way like
I'm rock hard for your rock guard yeah
that's gay but it's not be that as it
may I am I want your dick to be hard
dude be your being your best means
performing your best it's a wreck tile
without the function baby hard made easy
say hello to your little friend
so try him for a month today for just
five dollars will get you started for
just five bucks while supplies last see
the website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy so go to four hands calm slush
h3e D that's fo r h IM s.com /h 3 e d 4
hands calm /h 3e d
we're just going over this vape that we
had you are having your experts come in
and look at it yeah I have my guys look
at it and I think it's broken man is
that funny not this again
so yeah wait before we get started yeah
is it cool if I wear the beanie doubt
the talking being yeah you can put it on
it's you look mad no I'm thinking can
you actually well you'll see it's heavy
it's like it might not be wearable yeah
it's not be honorable
cuz that that's the vaping beanie or
it's coughing it's coughing being it
looks like it looks good man thank you
so yeah you can rock that of course less
I want to watch some of your music
videos is that okay yeah that would be
epic um I love him man I [ __ ] love
him so first the first I heard of you
you know this is the first I heard of
you was when I saw her I don't remember
how I even came across that I think it
was someone I saw it on Twitter or
something she's got the music off on the
[ __ ] music video is this a joke no
I'll put it on is going on here so this
video got 20 million views but it's even
though it's age restricted I mean that
must have really [ __ ] it [ __ ] me
man it's so annoying
I've been censored yes I'm just making
art making a piece about death
this shouldn't be like something that is
coveted from the world's eyes like it's
made it from the my perspective as an
artist it gave me a shaft really about
it now I'm constantly concerned about
what I can and cannot do I'm having to
compromise my visions I have to be
concerned about what I shown it's the
end of the day it's not really anything
you didn't really allistic I mean
there's birds flying out of my head like
it's a cartoon a hundred percent of yeah
well I don't understand because there's
a lot of huge music videos with billions
of views that are showing launched here
[ __ ] yeah a big problem is that you
those people are making them money so
they actually have something to lose
with my thing that nobody's watching
this compared to the billion plate music
video this is a [ __ ] joke but you
have a you're part of a big label right
you're with the big boy yes so they I
talk to you about this yeah and I tried
to have the label try to fight it
because we brought up so many examples
videos that are way more sexual way more
violent show graphic blood-spot are
people shooting each other in the head
yeah there's all kinds of it you know
I'm so mine is like it post moans a
rockstar there it's like a Kill Bill
bloodbath mm-hmm there's shitloads i
don't want to go out there calling after
people trying to get their video no no
that's not gonna happen that's not I
know but I'm saying there's so many
examples and I at the end of the day I
feel like I've been censored because I
used the SCOOTER crucifix and I think
that's why people are coming after me I
think it really has more to do with it's
a pair it's a religious parody that's
sensitive issue it's not like I'm even
making fun of anything I'm just making
an art piece about what I've seen in my
surroundings in my life and and I grew
up with family that was Catholic on one
side and so that was kind of shoved down
my throat and this is a byproduct of
that it's not something I try to do it's
just this is what it is well certain art
about your life you know certainly
you're not and I've been censored for
that you know I spoke to my people at
YouTube and they so what they told me
there's one scene where a tank blows off
your head and there's a little blood
right
so they said this specific moment is
with the birth oh yeah you have to be
living in a cartoon I was like girl
world to think that that's real life I
was so upset and then well they removed
it right breathing on age-restricted cuz
I had to label fight them yeah and then
it just got age-restricted again so it
didn't do anything in they try again
it's over they tried god they tried for
a long time it's snowing it's so [ __ ]
up LLL never open regardless you still
managed to get 20 million views on a
video that's ages for good that's
incredible and a testament to how
fantastic this video is so let's watch
it together sound on this time sound are
we on here let me test it let me test
the sound and see if it's on that's a
long cricket sound affect you maybe we
cut that down so here we go guys
this is Oliver tree hurt official music
video
full screen that [ __ ] dude what's going
on
you gotta cook quite a production value
on your music videos thank you very this
[ __ ] took seven months to make but some
of these ideas I've had this idea since
I was a kid this shot this shot
specifically singing getting brought
into the ambulance that's something I've
wanted to do since I was 12 years old so
that's kind of be crazy to see that come
to fruition yet I'm shocked that I even
got it to this point but now that's age
restricted doesn't even really matter
am I love it when musicians put so much
into the music videos thank you think it
adds so much they're really great you
don't see it anymore
you know since empty like MTV was the
heyday you still see cool music videos
yeah like this [ __ ] is like over the top
and I mean in a good way you know you
guys went all out
yeah it's because not only do I write
and produce my own music like it's
authentic coming from a real place but
then I write the videos and I also
direct them so it's really being able to
tell the full picture of the vision
here's what I'm gonna do I am a serial
video pause etre people on this on the
show know me as a serial video pause er
what I would like to do is play it
through without a pause let's do let's
watch it and then let's talk about it
because I think yes the whole thing does
that seem like a good idea let's do it I
think it's a good let's show these
[ __ ] kids what's good all right know
if you hate this that's okay if you love
this that's okay but we need to know is
this [ __ ] is raw and uncensored baby
we're gonna have to [ __ ] blur some of
it out so it can be on the podcast I
know at all my [ __ ] pocket schedule I
have to bleep get that scene I'm a few
which don't do it I'm not that censor
you dare yeah but you know what we can
do is post the highlight would be like
well this one's not age restricted
because we cut out that tank part now
we're talking right we're getting sand
then I'll name that highlight official
music video can we make a highlight of
that highlight yes here we go no pausing
two minutes everybody gear up get some
popcorn let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't always see your heart your tonight
should one days are so bad for you
this is that
[Music]
this is it I don't know what to do
cereal paws are dude stop [ __ ]
pausing it [ __ ] good I don't want my
old vodka so what's happening is there's
a bunch of Russian dudes on a tank and
they snipe his head you got a tank bro
yeah army check that's just real no CGI
here this part I have to yeah but it got
you a drink I know all you have to do
here we go so now you're going what's up
[ __ ] going on here dude real Blosser
I'm trying to help you man
well happy Mike everything
[Music]
[Music]
demons out here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you think this was part of history I
think so he's crucified to a giant razor
I thought so too but they said it was
the time I know this is Owen this is the
reason they're coming after me and then
they find any reason to be able to try
the age-restricted that's my theory
it's a razor well we got we did get a
district at once because we made a video
called Christian moms against dabbing
and they don't [ __ ] with any religious
[ __ ] there wait wait wait can I just say
something sure you just pause the
[ __ ] video in the middle that we were
talking about something that's
interesting maybe I'm a serial father
man it's a real here I'm gonna go back
so that we can capture them um all right
silent don't talk to me either
don't try to talk you wanna go Lena's
father this scene sucks dude there I
said it should have paid more for the
CGI I'm sorry say that again
I should have paid more for the CGI
there I said it that's practical effects
in it I'm not about to go in here saying
all my secrets dude yeah it's just done
all real
[Music]
we actually had to build the world's
biggest scooter
nothing practical about it
[Music]
so there's some kind of statement about
you being Jesus Christ right about here
like you kind of died on the scooter no
it's not that it's that I've sacrificed
my life for this and that's me giving my
everything right people so it's a
sacrifice how's it look I want to know
if hopper beanie etiquette how can we
make this thing look as good as it can
be
there's many suggestions there's a
there's machinery inside of it which
makes it difficult am i messing this
thing up did I brought yes well there's
there's some kind of gears and a vaping
mechanism yeah there's a lot so I've
broken this clearly is the mower time
come out of it no way
and so I brew and yet you ruined it for
sure you dropped it well you broke my
big babes and we're either how did I
break it so let's talk about this music
video all right you were in Ukraine for
eight months so we went across the world
to film this in Ukraine yeah the crazy
part about Ukraine and we film this any
Kiev crazy part about Ukraine is it's
pretty much mafioso out there you
actually pay the cops under the table
like bribe style like for your permit
yeah there is no permit process it's
like you have money built into the
budgets to be able to bribe the police
so smoking weed is illegal but if you
paid the police you can smoke weed
wherever you want shut down major
traffic shoot off army tango in the
middle of the street yeah that's cool
yeah why did you guys how did you guys
decide on on what if at the end of the
day everything in LA has pretty much
been filmed like a thousand times
so it's played out yeah so like let's do
it somewhere else and the idea became
about them like let's just get the [ __ ]
out of here I'm trying to dip and so we
just got on the next flight and we just
flew over there and we started the
process it took about seven months total
and we were in Kiev for a month straight
filming but it ended up being like with
the post and with every single part of
the editing and writing process it was
about eight or nine months but the ideas
have been curating for the last I would
say ten years starting load that's
amazing well
it really came together I mean thank you
it made me a fan it was the first thing
I saw yours and I was immediately like
and I just I kind of got enraged when I
saw was 8 restricted because I was like
this dude obviously put his heart and
soul and all the effort in the world
into this music fit for YouTube da
[ __ ] age-restricted
for know I was like what what possible
reason is there to age restrict this
[ __ ] video man I'm honored thank you
for that support man so everyone who's
watching this that means the world you
know if everyone could go check this
video out if you're logged into YouTube
you really want to watch it like you
should go check it out you know we mean
the world you know right now it's it's
pretty much backfired on itself and I
think that song it went number three on
alternative radio but the YouTube has
not taken off like it should have for a
song that's going to number three on
that so well it was the kind of thing
where no one can watch it they can't
even find it you can't really Google for
it they are not signed in right yeah it
makes you agree that you're over yeah
when when you're ageist forget it's very
very severe yeah I don't but I do
if you thought about uploading possibly
like a I couldn't do it he 13 Britain
yet to understand I'm an actual artist I
just have this is how I do it this is it
and I've been currently just trying to I
have to scale back some of my ideas and
I'm constantly like being concerned
about what do I have to cut out I'll
tell you what and to get age-restricted
yeah let's hear it if you have I know
people on YouTube like the people who
make these decisions you know the
bigwigs in charge yes thing and so we
can pitch them if you have a specific
idea you say hey can I show this they'll
tell you yes or no that and you can get
an actual answer you don't have to guess
right which is something help Smee a lot
yeah well hey are you in touch I need to
talk to these [ __ ] people yeah but
yeah I mean you set the record straight
I went to youtube I said how do we fix
this they said look into it no call back
eight months later YouTube I'm gonna
follow up with my guy I'm gonna follow
up and see if you can do it I think this
thing is broken
dude I don't know but there's something
about you I have bad like everything you
touched today mechanically has broken
and I don't I'm just noticing some kind
of trend
dan can help yo can we guess can we get
someone to help can we get a drum roll
please
Zach we get the drum roll that guy with
the drum roll
[Music]
dan is fixing the mic Oliver is taking a
sip of his coffee and go ahead you can
and we are in the h3 podcast what is
popping yeah we're back I'm gonna follow
up and see it but yeah it's such a
tragedy you guys go but at any rate it's
a masterpiece it really is so much oh
yeah and I guess you know the one thing
I didn't say is like the the most the
travesty of it all was this was not in a
really cheap video to make this show was
extremely expensive we made a
documentary about the making of it which
is fantastic I made this music video
with the small loan of a million dollars
from Atlantic Records it was initially
going to be 500,000 I was able to raise
it to 750,000 then and by the end of it
by after the whole post and editing and
all the special effects I ended up
coming out to just over a million
dollars and to spend a million dollars
on a two and a half minute music video
that gets aid restricted it's pretty
[ __ ] up oh my goodness it's always
been devastating to everyone at the
label they don't want to give me more
money to do bigger videos cuz they're
like this shit's literally just wasting
our money I we were wondering about that
like how do you guys afford that yes so
my music videos are pretty grandiose
compared to an artist that doesn't have
a album out or is a new artist the way I
set my deal up was that I carved out
half the money I was supposed to get I
put it into marketing budgets to make
the music videos bigger so you're paying
for it I'm paying for every every penny
I get goes right into the production
right into the music video now that I'm
directing it's cheaper too because I'm
not paying 10 percent to some director
or their agent fee I'm able to just put
every penny back into the production so
you're seeing like every bit of the
money being put back in and at the end
of the day like the product is quality
but Wow you know I'm reached this point
where I can't afford to make another
million dollar music video and have this
[ __ ] age-restricted
the label will literally drop me but
you're paying for it I'm paying them
back they give me a loan essentially and
I pay them back because you know I mean
it's just setup as they're a bank and
I'm just basically extorting them for as
much money as a manager and at the end
of the day I put every penny back into
their product so how can you complain
Atlantic Records
do they complain they gotta be a no and
yeah they're amazing shout out to my
people over there you guys know the
story about how I got signed no I love
the earth so this isn't something I
actually talked about that was actually
a trick question just seeing if you guys
watched any of my interviews I did you
do any research at all for this yes I
know you did
I'm looking at you yes dude probably
just a lot of you and you should have
seen my vape tutorials you don't have
able to Toros of course I do see I've
done research you don't have a tutorial
I have them and they're on my old
youtube account
Madden yep we don't have that good of
research come on you're not not you
think Ian's gonna dip dip that deep dude
ian is [ __ ] incredible don't talk
[ __ ] about him and I am I gonna play it
boy Dansby tutorials bro come on no dude
at the end of the day you got a great
team again you don't need to talk [ __ ]
on in the intern just because he's an
intern you know like just because I told
them that fidget spinner was one kind
doesn't mean I don't [ __ ] with them like
I love him I love his research yeah he
really has taken this podcast in the
entire show to the next level and you
know it's good guy who's got the data
and you know can give the research and
then you just do your you know informed
opinion and I think that's quite a
powerful approach thank you very much
what were we talking about back to the
music video so what happened was the
label tells me I'm not making another
one of these [ __ ] videos how did you
get sign to Atlantic so is that a that
was something I was oh come on did you
really are breaking our [ __ ] that was a
gift from somebody that means a lot to
me and I do think probably I mean you
really are breaking it I don't care okay
no wait do I need to stop you can wear
it but it is No
stop dropping it yeah I'm not trying
let's watch another music okay I'll let
me tell you see all right I'm gonna set
this up one last time yeah okay sure
it wasn't I'm sure laughs all right I
just want to say this little story okay
so are you with me we good so far
so this is the story of how I signed
with Atlantic Records they fly me out to
New York for an interview the CEO Craig
Kalman is sitting at the end of this
hallway that my managers called me and
Oliver come out I'm wearing this full
outfit I come out on my scooter I'm
ready I take I'm taking my head off I'm
riding no hands and this guy's like oh
wow and then I go I do a 360 I fall I
make it look like I hit my head I've got
blood capsules in my mouth I just start
spitting the blood on its cover my son
like thinks he has a lawsuit on
everything and I'm just like stop nice
to meet you sir thanks for having me out
here and I went right into the business
pitch and afterwards like what would you
think of him he's like oh he's Olivia's
haven't come back next week
so he's some nerdy Jill come on dude no
you don't need to make this Semitic it's
only somatic bro
everything is somatic I don't even okay
but to be frank hell of a guy
he ended up taking on the project and
signing it to Atlantic and and here we
are at the h3 podcast so is that a true
story
that's a [ __ ] true story and that was
a big deal for me actually getting the
deal I wanted because when you prank the
CEO of the company people start to be
like we want to work on the he pranked
our boss hell yeah and I had set it up
so that I had allocated the proper
budget so that I could afford to have
the art budgets to have the same art
department that is working on Ed
Sheeran's videos and Bruno Mars's you
know like and they're all their cover
art I mean while I have the same budget
as those artists because I just took all
the money and put it into the promotion
side so it's the kind of thing where I
could work with these people and then
like I was able to get the building
behind me and once you start pranking
and more pulling off some of this stuff
that I did the word gets out and then
the building gets behind you and you
gotta have the building behind you
before you know you're gonna be able to
I wish I knew [ __ ] you were telling the
truth this is fact I haven't told the
story before but it's honestly a true
story who's your manager is he here yeah
can you put him on uh Dan is he in the
building he's in the building put him on
the put him on the camera let's see
what's his name it's all blurry what
happened you vaping into the camera
there dad what the [ __ ] going on over
there let me see the switch you to him
your cameras all blurry
anyway let's let's get a look at
Bigler what's your name Dana wad
what are you doing a great tie say his
name wrong what'd you say
Dana wad Dave his name's Dane we call
them insane Dane Oh Dame okay so you
were there during the pitch on the
scooter yeah this is a 1000% true story
how can I be more than a hundred percent
true it's a thousand percent and whose
idea was it it was mine okay so here's
the funny part this guy and what did you
mean yes guy who was the A&R who didn't
end up being my A&R NRA's artisan
repertoires the person who signs the
artists and kind of helps them be their
liaison at the label so this guy he's
like this is the one chance I work with
Oliver tree come prank my boss so
someone else idea to prank the boss but
uh I didn't even remember that he just I
was going to school at the time at
CalArts
and he was he called me one day at
school he's like hey man you want to
come to New York to do the meeting and
I'm like yeah let's do it he's like I'll
call you a red-eye tonight so I fought
in New York I get there and I haven't
slept and he's like so what's the big
trick and I'm like oh [ __ ] big prank I'm
like get me a razor scooter and some
fake blood tablets that's amazing and
now how you get signed I mean it's true
you want to make an impression
impression and um well you were you guys
what says the president - they're not
gonna box me in as some type of artist
that they're trying to fill in to their
roster it's like this guy's gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants is a loose
can you set these kind of levels allow
me to kind of get away with what I want
to and set them up being like look if
you guys aren't ready for some out there
this ain't the right project for you
that's really smart you know I've gone
into some meetings as myself and you
have like there's like you're [ __ ]
boring well you're like do I put on do I
dress nice and go in and get all proper
but it's like bro I'm I'm a comedian
that's my job I don't yeah you're I'm
gonna go in there I'm gonna go in there
with sandals cuz that they want that
right they want the guy wearing Sam gone
with socks and sandals that's it why why
do they want anything else
socks and sandals are you go layer one
arc and razor well that's that's we
always got the socks oh my goodness I'll
put this away I wish I could wear this
the whole interview man why don't you it
does the beanie separate from the
mechanics I think so so you could do
that
yeah it's already broken I'm gonna throw
it out after you leave anyway so it's
fine well it does open all right let's
see yeah we're desecrating this part no
I'm not
yeah well then if that's the case let me
just wear this thing do you want any
beanie dant get him a beanie for
Christ's sake Robbie just destroyed our
set - were you guys worried if that was
a good idea or not or you're like this
is dumb
what was the beanie with you in the
manager Dane dude here's the thing man
Dane what were your thoughts on that did
you were you worried about that stunt
I'll just tell you what because Dave's
not day and it's actually dan dan what I
you know DJ Danny man D man get over
here
were you were you uh were you worried
about that stunner were you on board
honestly that's really like nothing
compared to some of the [ __ ] Oliver like
plans and makes us go through so that
was like a very light-hearted like well
hold on there do you have any other
anecdotes honestly like I can't really
you know this is Oliver's moment I'm
gonna let him tell what he wants to tell
dude let's put it this way him he's a
good man last week got your back I had I
have a driver this driver picked up on
one day I shouldn't say too much but one
day he picks up a three and a half pound
joint the next day he goes and picks up
a race car and then the day after that
we had to go and rent this whole bouncy
house so it's like you know every day is
a different thing but I'm requesting all
kinds of stuff I'm like hey I need to
get the painting from my sister I need
you to make sure that it's in the frame
I'm asking for all this [ __ ] and so I'm
making him jump through hoops but you
know there's no other real way to do
this yeah you got your mission
we're on a mission and we got an
incredible team some of the most epic
people just a team of about 40 or 50 I
mean who makes your clothing one second
it's a team of 45 who are able to work
together on one yeah it's a huge team
think about Oliver Leonardo DiCaprio and
he painted the Sistine Chapel right I'm
with you so when Leonardo da Vinci
painted the 16th chapel what what you
see there is not the work of one man he
did army of people yeah he must have had
at least 15 guys helping him paint this
what you're seeing with all of a tree
project it's a team of 45 people that
are all working extremely hard it allows
me to be basically a giant baby I
haven't driven for a year and a half I
haven't cooked a meal for two and a half
years and I don't pay bills I don't sign
anything I have a team of people who
just signed my signatures for me so
that's great I'm basically just a giant
baby that's great just sitting around
making art well that's the well you know
that's your bread and butter you have to
enable yourself the less the the more
time you spend not doing that the worse
you know 100% I mean I we find that it
also comes at a certain cost like in
what sense do you feel like you don't
have your privacy or um well okay let's
say this I haven't lived anywhere from
last year I live in hotels
things like sometimes I'm sleeping on
the couch
it's always different but it's like I
get home from my recording session at 5
in the morning
what kind of you think I really care
about what I'm sleeping on you know what
I mean like I'm about to go to sleep for
a couple hours wake up and do it all
over again so kind of in this kind of
make it or break it phase where it's
like if I go hard now it's it's easy
I'll be able to totally ride it out but
if I don't it's like you know you don't
have any regrets yeah I mean it's really
just the kind of thing where I have a
moment here to prove myself and if I
don't go with it all the way then I've
wasted the last 10 years of my life
mm-hmm go big or go home baby it's as
simple as that
that's it you're in the hustle you're in
the grind man I sleep I sleep like three
hours a night you're ready to have a
baby yeah we're on the same sleep spit
bro I truly think and I'm and I'm gonna
say this now from the heart from a
genuine place and I want everyone
listening to take to open their ears I
think you're gonna I think you're gonna
go big I think you already did well you
are big hasn't even started yet we
haven't even dropped an album we're in
the middle of the diggity oh why you
have achieved so far
thank you I know I know you're feeling
bad about how this video came out but
the fact that as 20 million views and
age-restricted is kind of like that is
Crane [ __ ] crowd I appreciate that
but I'm on a label and I'm competing
against artists that have a billy in
place so this is a [ __ ] joke - yeah
you know what I mean so we can't be
celebrating just yet let's not start
sucking let's not jinx it okay
no but I but let okay let's not let's
not and I'm dead expectations but I will
say this I think you're a talent I think
you're unique I think you have a unique
voice I think you're a talented musician
you've got a vision of vision you're
willing to put in the work you are
willing to get it done at any cost you
are willing to sleep on the couch you
are willing to crucify yourself on a
giant scooter I mean what else can you
say about the the lad right well man
thing I mean you know we're working on
building the world's biggest scooter
right now good I've been talking with
engineers for the last seven months we
have a bunch of different people that
have put together basically a range of
them starts around 600,000 and they come
down the bottom tiers around 200,000 but
we're trying to build the world's
biggest scooter right now I'm telling
them no we're not selling them are you
trying to beeline to 600,000 well I'm
saying there's a range of trying to get
nice cheap you know what's the cheapest
and so the cheapest we can make this
world's biggest scooter this is gonna be
like $200,000 harpists so if there's
anybody watching this who wants to help
start a crowdfunding page I think we
could probably get the money together to
build the world's biggest scooter
together so where did where do you ride
that thing probably a racetrack that'll
be fast quick
yeah but I'm actually seriously working
on it oh thank you so much oh wait so
let's go over beanie etiquette real
quick yeah so you want the sticker on
the side okay sticker on the side duly
noted
yeah there now you're looking fresh you
want to pull it up a little more I mean
that's spicy hot that's like that's like
a straight-up thumbtack bro so you're
saying I look good
I'm really good thank you bro
let's watch another music value have
another one that's like totally off the
rails in a good way - although that that
last music video hurt you say is about
an epic scooter crash yeah it's about a
scooter crash that nearly took my life
and I thought you were goofing around
that's from the genius interview right
but then I saw on Twitter
you had the how do you say receipts
right for anyone who thought I was lying
when I said my song hurt was about
breaking both my wrist and thumbs in a
screw crash [ __ ] you this was the worst
summer of my life
it was [ __ ] up ham bro what happened
how do you go how do you get that damage
from a scooter crash so I used to
compete professionally
and scooter raises no it's scooter
freestyle so thanks so I did every
action sport in the book I grew up
motorcycling bmxing downhill racing but
a middle school I really started
focusing in on scootering in 2009 when I
was 16 I signed with the Junior
syndicate team so I got on a scooter
team and I was competing nationally
around the country and basically this
day was I was 18 years old so this is
like this is the end this was the last
competition I ever did but I'm rolling
in on this 20 foot rolling come in and
semi final run and I've know where this
little [ __ ] pebble shows up I hit
this I go flying break both my wrist
break my thumb you know the whole nine I
have a gnarly concussion too they're
like that was the worst part because
lamb do your head on it I hit my head
super hard I don't even remember where I
was and so that part was dangerous
because if you hit your head hard enough
and you know I've hit my head a lot of
times because I've been doing the action
sports for a while so the damage can be
like not good yeah unrepairable yeah not
good so I'm in the hospital I get metal
rod through my hand the entire summer
and my girlfriend took care of me and
fed me wiped my ass did the whole
[ __ ] thing I was just I was a mess
and after that I was like I don't think
this is a safe line of work for me like
I don't think this is something that I'm
gonna have longevity so I started
switching over to a different field and
I started writing some music at that
time and I've always made music growing
up but this at that time I started just
writing about the experience and I
started making a couple tracks and those
songs were the ones that got me signed
with Atlantic Wow yeah so it's crazy
because I mean it sounds cheesy but it's
definitely I would say divine
intervention it's basically like you
know well my life's path has been like
changed because of this one crash how
did you end up choosing scooter among
all the other extreme sports right I
mean I did every single one like for
example you saw the alien boy video with
the monster truck so I spent six months
at the Paris Auto Speedway learning how
to jump this thing I actually got to
drive this on a weekly basis and this
guide only let two people drive his car
me and Jay Leno like it's the kind of
thing where these engines they blow out
$400 and $400,000 engine and if the
engine blows
there's no like oh you can return the
engine it's just you're [ __ ] you used
it for hundred grand so they don't let
people ride him around it's not the kind
of thing you ride around town you can
only really ride him at tracks and
limited amount it's more about the jumps
so I learned how to jump but always done
every type of action sport I think the
scooter just fit well cuz I seen I was
like nobody's nobody's riding the
scooter what's that about and I'm like
you know what if I got I'm on the other
things I'd be [ __ ] dope you know it
would look crazy through the scooter
ties into the ties into the music sick
dude it really does I mean and when I
see you ripping crazy tricks on the
scooter I almost don't even believe it's
real thank you it's surreal thank you I
appreciate that because the thing is
like at the end of the day when it comes
down to is packaging everything you have
to offer and so what I've done with this
project is just put together all right
sorry but does that I disrespect what
was it I was trying I'm just checking
cuz I'm not sure about wasn't well I I
went you know when I when I found out
that you were a serious scooter or I
look a search I did I was like is that a
I almost didn't I mean no offense but I
never heard such a thing right it's all
good it's pretty underground yeah it's
definitely like pretty underground cuz
when I think of razors razor scare the
[ __ ] out of me these things do not hit
your shin you're done oh yeah I've had
some you should see this some of my my
ankles just puff up when this thing will
hit me on miss tell it's so painful
black and blue the whole nine have you
ever taken any other serious injuries
besides oh I've taken many did I broken
eight bones so mountain biking
motorcycling I've broken this wrist
three times broken the humerus even
broke my femur at one point I've taken
quite a few spills are you still act
every soul yeah I still scooter all the
time but I don't compete anymore it's
just for fun yeah and I'm just doing
like nothing not not really the bigger
tricks I just kind of keep it more
low-key and and try to make it so it's
nothing that's gonna potentially
endanger or you know mess up everything
everyone heart music I don't want to
take any serious injuries yeah but I was
looking I was blown away by these these
guys are incredible dude I mean look at
these guys a true athlete on these
razors this is a great video actually
instituted since said well that's
thirteen million view of those like yeah
there's one trick here yeah this I love
this part someone actually made an edit
of this music video with my face on it
for all the different really yeah I
should try to pull it up that somebody
one see there was one trick here that
totally [ __ ] blew my mind here yeah
let's see maybe that's not it
that was pretty dumb so were you doing
these kind of trick I can do this is all
pretty fairly rudimentary so what about
that one
that is definitely complex but it looked
like if I'm not mistaken a flare
tripletail up and I can definitely leave
are you doing a flare tripletail up I I
haven't done a quadruple but there was a
couple of occasions where I was able to
do a triple mostly I try to just keep it
low-key less spinning now you almost did
a double back fakie the name sound like
you're making them up no yeah but I
guess they're real I mean that's what I
mean I was clean yeah the skater ones
are pretty phony too you know yeah it
sound like they're made up but there you
have it yeah your your your got it like
a very proactive personality you're very
mean by that well I mean like at a young
age you're competing very aggressively
right and I think I pulled some of them
were additive nature into what I'm doing
musically definite because I grew up
just constantly racing different bikes
doing these different freestyle
competition very hungry though like yeah
I want more I think I'm a very I think
by nature lazy person but when I hear
your story
it's incredible that you were so
competitive and so skilled at that age
and then immediately already segue right
into music and you're already making
music my whole life that wasn't like it
just came out of nowhere you're doing so
much and you're very good at a lot of
things I think read about thing well I'm
the kind of person who's just ah you
know as the human condition just feels
like it's never enough like no matter
how much we accomplish how much it's
just like alright like I'm not even
close and when you actually accomplish
your dreams it ends up feeling like this
is just a day job now you know and then
your your what your other passions
become your real dreams and so like me
being a musician is no longer like a
dream it's just like that's my day job
grab do all this radio promotion and all
this [ __ ] I don't want to have to do
that makes it feel like this is a day
job so then you start dreaming you're
like well the grass is always greener on
the
I want more like I want to be a filmic I
want to make the best movies ever made
and so it's the kind of thing where is
that you're dreaming about now that's
where I'm trying to go and that's why
I'd chose to put so much money into the
marketing budgets my music videos is
because as an unknown filmmaker who the
[ __ ] is gonna give me a million dollars
to make it two and a half minute video
for sure maybe one reason why that
should even ever happen no no and I
found this one basic thing that is like
a cheat code and I'm kind of exploiting
it going like using one key from one
castle to open up another castle and as
the artist it makes sense for me to be
spending videos and it makes sense for
me to be directing them to get the most
pure authentic vision that isn't just
someone else's idea of what this world
is so in 10 years from now you want to
be making full-feature yeah I'm already
writing feature films I'm working on a
few different things but you have to
write like six of them before you're
gonna make one of ours and I've been
trying to make an animated TV show for
two and a half years and I'm pretty sure
it just failed I don't know we we
already pitched it yeah doesn't look
good
how do you grow you just suck in what
happens is at the the level that I've
recently got to is that your team has to
be super efficient super good organizing
and what you do is you just organize it
all in and I can do a week's worth of
work in one day like do you run out and
do one thing and then just hit five do
six you have a nice schedule you
schedule your day we do it very tight
every basically from the second I wake
up to the second I go to sleep I am
working when do you wake up I wake up it
varies like for example I was just doing
sessions that I would stay up till 5:00
in the morning so last night I didn't
have the session so I got to go to bed I
had to go to bed earlier so I could wake
up today for this but normally it's
anywhere from eight o'clock to one in
the morning one or one p.m. 8:00 a.m. to
1:00 1:00 p.m. and then the end of the
day start taking a little coffee at 5:00
p.m. you know and then all of a sudden
it's 5:00 in the morning and you're
still in the studio you know that's the
kind of thing so you have a it seems
like you you're relying your team law do
you ever have to discipline them like
how do you know it's bad but I mean like
they get out of line sometimes and but
the truth is you can't get physical with
them right that's illegal
that's illegal but what you can do is
like I just trick them into doing all
sorts of [ __ ] that I don't even need
just to [ __ ] with them like do
I had him get this whole night 600
balloons I'm like yo we need balloons
for this little party there's me
meanwhile there's no party there's
nothing they just get all this [ __ ] but
that's gotta test them that's a test you
got to keep them on and that's also how
you make sure you know you have people
that are loyal around you that's how I
know they're legit they're not you know
if I ask for the six hundred balloons
there's no questions they're gonna
deliver right that's a test that's a
loyalty test Ian we need six hundred
balloons bro let's [ __ ] tomorrow
morning right yes sir we having a party
[ __ ] can't say [ __ ] sorry you got this
wrong
maybe I explained it tell me again so
important to value your workers right
like these guys wait what yeah they're
workers Oh value of degree through mail
I try I try to let them feel like
they're valued even if that may or may
not be the case and I'll often just be
like you know the power of just saying
our page instead of my page you know
like I always said I wouldn't [ __ ] with
them it's definitely my page but it's
like dude this is our page we got to get
the [ __ ] video our video up meanwhile
I'm just like you know you know I just
[ __ ] with them all the time to like we
will all have a make like edit together
like a half-hour documentary and I'll be
like yeah let's cut that down to like
two minutes yeah you gotta take people
on your toast you hear that again you
don't think you have it bad come on give
me a break discusses these guys on this
[ __ ] wait what we're gonna say this guys
to what what it what just make me say
what can I get one second yeah sure that
might be graphic I think a little got
out you're right I mean nothing could
top the first time so we're good you
guys aren't gonna show that right oh
yeah it's fun definitely we can cut out
some of this stuff no host right no way
live baby you're joking
you're [ __ ] with me well we used no
we're not we're not eating Dan let's
watch another video cool tell me with it
uh tell me about this video here this is
the other one that really struck stuck
out to me this was the all that yep now
where did you get I usually we keep the
sound on when we're showing the video
yeah we do things a little different
here beige we bought guts so wait are we
gonna be pausing it every 5 seconds or
how does this okay so let's let's um you
know what I'm gonna do for you I've
never done this this is epic I can't
wait to see this cuz I've never seen it
I have never done this but here's
world's bird I'm gonna play it and I'm
gonna lay down on the couch
are you serious you're not gonna be
watching you you're gonna monitor action
no I'm gonna fail you could lay both
ways on a couch bro um but this is the
best for everybody we're just gonna let
it play cool you guys you're not gonna
say anything I'm not gonna I could talk
afterwards for like six seven minutes
straight seven hours oh yeah we're gonna
play the full documentary as well yeah I
won't say anything so here we go
for real screen that [ __ ] I swear to god
I'll pause it if I'm here we've got a
full screen this I don't know what the
program is here but we need to get Wow
he's just desizing
that's on purpose
okay
[Music]
just so people know that was actually me
jumping
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Susie is the best part
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from a hundred miles away but I still
make it work but it's overrated and
somehow played out
[Music]
thank you thank you did you step on my
sister's painting that was a really
beautiful production and thank you
appreciate that so that was another big
one you probably spent a couple clams on
that one a spent some time on that that
[ __ ] it's crazy those first two videos I
I was spending so much money on the
videos that could only make one a year
so that's why it's like I can't afford
to make videos like that anywhere I have
to kind of scale it down a little bit
but I'm working on a couple videos right
now and and I'm trying to bring back the
bigger budgets yeah I've been fighting
with the label I'm in the process of
fighting them for an album date they
keep pushing it back and every day me
why did they move it back I hear that
from yeah the artist why do they do that
I have no idea it's ready for you you're
ready oh I'm ready and they're pushing
it back that's so strange this day you
know I think they're just the edge of
their seats you know oh they know what
they're doing watching this car wreck
waiting to happen I guess they know what
they're doing though
we'll see dude we're about to see yeah
we'll see but yeah I mean at this point
there's a love/hate relationship with
the label you know you really you got a
fight head to head yeah but you know
these people they believe in what I do
so I'm very honored to found yeah
because that you know I've been on other
labels I was in a really bad situation
with the old deal that I couldn't
release music and I couldn't release
music for like four years so I don't
know if your information found that out
but I was on the hiatus
did you figure did you know that yeah he
says no you didn't know that the [ __ ] is
going on here I told you I was a fan of
your research you don't make me take
that back so huh so tell me about that
how what does a bad relationship with a
label look like I'm not allowed to talk
about it too much because I've signed
paperwork what can you say but I can say
it's just the kind of thing of being
shelf to put onto a shelf whoa you
basically just make music that doesn't
ever see the light of day and you kind
of go crazy so when I or when I did my
next I was like set it up so that if if
the label doesn't want to release it I
can still put the [ __ ] out myself and
Warner Brothers will still distribute it
so for a much smaller percentage but
they will see you no one can tell me
what I can or can't put out and that's
I'm in a place of power with create
now there's nobody who say you have to
do this or you can't do that I'm like Oh
dila you can be working on songs and
they would just I've made going I have
like 15 albums I've made like so much
music and 90% of an artist music will
never come out concede and so that's
that music is still owned by your
previous label no I was able to set it
up and buy back the rights and
everything but it's crazy I mean to not
be able to release your own art yeah it
seems crazy and then when you really
work at the label though I mean you
wouldn't want to like be releasing music
without the label the whole point is
you're like partnered up with them so if
you're already being owned by them it's
like you might as well have the funding
to do what you want so I just don't
understand what they have the game by
not releasing you know they were just
letting me develop it was a development
thing because when I was 18 this is a
very long time ago and I was able to
find go through you got to get it out of
your system and just spend time and I've
made at least upwards of almost a
thousand songs probably so you think
there was some wisdom in their decision
there was a little bit but the thing was
that if you are gonna just hold me back
from reaching my potentials and I'm just
gonna shut the doors and then close in
you know I have to figure out another
solution so I had to go back to school
and tried to recalibrate things and I
started over from scratch I had other
projects in the past and you just got to
start over and build from the ground
floor up again let me ask you how many
of those jackets you know what kind of
smell it yeah cuz come over here and
smell my armpit
you gotta smell this no I swear to god
there's only one smell the pit no get in
the pit yeah did I did I literally just
no smell inside the armpit yeah so I
didn't put on deodorant for you
specifically I hope you don't smell it
from there but do you really only have
one of those but how do you take sort of
care of it don't you get all crazy it's
really quality where'd you get that
what's the brand I took this from my
mom's closet this is something I would
wear when I was eight or nine I would go
skiing with this thing and she wasn't
using it so I said [ __ ] it I'm just
gonna take this and I think I'm getting
a lot more use out if it's a special I
mean it's you've gotten the mileage out
of that yeah this thing is
Zach will use only one Ella spit usually
anything for the show right yeah I'll
smile oh yeah is that kidding here in
smells pet would you alright is this
mess this is ice a loyalty test
is how we know how legit this is man
let's get you in here quick okay here
comes Zach here he comes
so apparently okay zach is now
destroying our so Zach our sound guy
welcome Zach he's shreds on the guitar
he's a great ed go ahead and sniff
Oliver spit how's it going
get in there nice and deep now Zach
thank you yep cheesy does it feel like a
smell that's been there for a minute
like that's like a historic smell yeah a
little mussed yeah I haven't more
deodorant for about three weeks just for
this interview I've been building it up
good work Zack I wanted to make sure
yeah thank you for testing that
appreciate you anything for the show you
see that hand take note yeah he's moving
up dude
zach is gonna replace me in like two F's
no time you know next time I'll be
coming and bringing in gifts for him
finally there's two other things we are
at the bottom of the show I have two
things I want to ask you about one is is
the haircut real are you serious right
now is that a real bowl cut bro I don't
like getting into this this is something
that I specifically said I don't want to
talk about that's why I asked you
because I like to hit hard I like to I
take I ask the question
you invite me to your podcast and you
disrespect me my hair you read a real
book I've what's the problem it's not a
real bull cut then what's what's for the
issue there's no issue here I just don't
like people asking about my personal
life your hair bro everyone can see dude
you really want to see this [ __ ] yeah
man yeah sure
please let's see it we've been dying to
know no it's not my real [ __ ] here
you think I'd have some dumbass haircut
like that this is all for show biz
really yeah can we see a real hair dome
I'm curious
take it off let's take a look you've got
a really cool password that yeah we're
the hey it looks like you have little
hairs you know coming in looks slick bro
what the [ __ ] are you saying you've got
a little skullcap with hairs like pokey
hairs am I crazy do you know what I'm
talking about Neela okay I know he's
doing a bit but I'm not doing a [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude this is my life we're talking
about this isn't a [ __ ] another one
of your live podcast jokes so this is my
livelihood so why are you wearing a wig
right now I may or may not have bleached
the hair blonde and I'm doing another
look so you're covered so you had a bulk
up previously yes and that's your I came
here to talk about I wanted to set the
[ __ ] record straight yes I changed
the hair yeah but you guys aren't going
to see the full reveal yet that comes
later
how much later let me see it you know
what seeing [ __ ] this is as much as
you're about to see clean up all right
oh I didn't want to ask you you know you
tweeted out when you announced your tour
over at Oliver Tree music.com get
tickets a bit quickly right right that
this is your last tour yeah then Oliver
tree is gonna die or something no no no
he's nothing like that it's just but why
is this your last tour what does that
mean oh it's just I spent the last year
living in hotels traveling out of a
suitcase and to be honest with you
[ __ ] sucks yeah I didn't get into
making music to go promote this [ __ ] and
travel non-stop just playing for one
hour a day you end up being on air
planes buses green rooms sitting in a
hotel for the bulk of your existence
it's not how I want to spend my life so
at the end of the day I have to make
some decisions about what I want to do
with my time here and I don't want to
waste my time traveling around the world
playing shows when I can't even have
time to make art that's why I was born
on this planet to have actually a
creative lifestyle and I don't feel like
I can do that while I'm constantly on
the road promoting this [ __ ] and doing
interviews and [ __ ] like this like
stuff like this is a prime example yeah
so you're basically you're gonna not do
tours but you're gonna it's gonna give
you more time to it's gonna give me more
time to make more videos films and focus
on Latinos yeah
and I'm I'm in the process of making
arguably
the craziest debut album an artist did
have a release so I'm in the process of
working on that I will not fail to
deliver that good I've been working on
it for 10 years wow this is you know 15
albums this is my greatest hits album
this is me picking all the best [ __ ] and
no and that's the craziest part is that
that's what it is to be an artist you
just make and make it making what the
general public sees 5% of it so people
don't know [ __ ] they don't know about
the other projects I had in between you
know it's just this kind of thing do you
have a tentative release date that's the
thing then the label keeps pushing back
on it they keep saying three more months
six more months and here we are two
years after the fact they told me I had
to just do one EP at first and now
they're saying maybe another EP and I'm
just like dude what the [ __ ] is going on
here so I'm fighting my lawyer is
fighting with them every single day
we're working on it we're trying to get
a date for the album I'm sorry to
everybody we can't get the album out
sooner but we're working hard I think
it's going to be a worth the way god
bless and I have one final question or a
fan favorite what is Evernote when you
get someone like this in the studio so
you got to ask have you ever had a
paranormal experience with ghosts UFOs
aliens have you ever had a paranormal
experience it's not something that I've
shared with very many people just a
couple close friends right but when I
was 8 years old I saw ghosts at my
grandmother's house she has this room
that's filled with like all these horse
like was it some kind of horse Pony type
toys that are on the walls and I was
sleeping one night I'm sitting in there
and I hear this voice laughing I look
over to me and there's this I don't want
to say it's just the shape of an outline
I can't really see I couldn't like I
couldn't really make out what it was
exactly but I've seen this ghost and 6
years later when I went back to her
house I saw the same ghost and then I
found out she said that my grandpa
apparently haunted the place and so I'm
not sure if because my grandpa died
before I was born
so I'm not sure if if it was
trying to connect with me or maybe it
was one of my cousins trying to [ __ ]
with me I don't know but like you'd
think six years later I'd be able to
tell like I'm a grown-ass man by then
what what did it look like it's kind of
like a round kind of around orifice you
could see the aura that's kind of the
best way I could put it you could see
this aura and I was kind of taken back I
was like is that clear ball you said it
wow that sounds emotional yeah [ __ ] up
that was the first time I met my grandpa
yeah so well thank you for sharing that
I know that that's a better story here
and I'm really grateful to be here big
fan of what you guys do thank you I
haven't considered doing any podcast
this was the one place I felt like I
could actually come and be able to feel
at home and be you know with the right
people and you guys are incredible
things I love what you do thank you so
much fans will be following closely
can't wait for the album can't wait for
every video all of our tree guys you
know what time it is
you hurry here shake the hand to another
to a fellow vape God I bow think now you
and I won one more time guys Oliver tree
music.com catch this man on his last
tour this is it 80% sold out so get
those fricking tickets while they're up
let's do it hurt go look up but you have
to specifically type hurt Oliver tree
because those [ __ ] are not
helping you can't find it can't find the
[ __ ] you sign my glasses oh sorry my
glasses bro holy [ __ ] wait can we keep
these definitely not we're gonna need to
get back all the gifts alright guys
thank you for watching
so what's happening he's packing
everything up right I mean I don't know
what you would need that back boys
it's literally a portrait of me and my
he's packing up he's grabbing the baby
stuff and I'm not really sure what
you're gonna hang that up or you gonna
you can't really read if that thanks for
having me on the shows dope and hope to
come back sometime and talk more about
it okay Oliver tree everyone we have
next to on Tuesday we have Chris D'Elia
joining us the cameras to the right yeah
there you go oh you got it bite me
already the Hollywood strip so there you
heard it uh crying Chris D'Elia
and Oliver tree have beef apparently and
we'll have to resolve that about not so
Tuesday we'll see you then and then
Friday we're having another show
so it's ashli podcast all day every day
you know what you know you know what it
is this is yours truly Oh Jay Simpson
here
what up Twitter world this Vigi spinners
smooth well that was a lot of fun thank
you guys once again we'll see you on on
Tuesday have a blessed weekend and uh
god
frickin thank you I cap so bad at any of
these partners you know how do I end
this you just say have fun on the
weekend I said that okay um thanks for
watching I said that big big pimps yeah
we should end on that okay it's for the
world this is yours truly see you on
Tuesday thanks Dan Kelly
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]